[Música]
hola esto es aquí américa el magazine de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente yo soy natalia cabrera y esto
es lo que veremos hoy en la antesala de
la cumbre de las américas en los ángeles
no hay lista oficial de invitados tras
el boicot e iniciado por el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador en nombre de
méxico al que se sumaron naciones como
honduras y las que integran la comunidad
del caribe caricom para exigir la
presencia de cuba nicaragua y venezuela
y seguimos en eeuu pero en la capital
porque los nombres de las calles son
ahora una herramienta política un
fenómeno que nació cuando se rebautizó
en la calle frente a la casa blanca como
black life matters plaza les explicamos
de la mano de nuestro corresponsal en la
capital estadounidense y visitamos
venezuela a pesar de que existe el
derecho a cambiar de nombre y de género
las autoridades electorales y el
servicio de identificación no estarían
permitiendo realizar el trámite les
traemos la historia desde caracas
y para empezar hablemos de todo nuestro
continente los jefes de estado y de
gobierno de las américas tienen la rara
oportunidad de reunirse bajo un mismo
techo en los ángeles del 6 al 10 de
junio para buscar acuerdos en los
problemas transversales del hemisferio
como lo son la migración récords la
polarización política el respeto a la
democracia e incluso las consecuencias
de la guerra rusa en ucrania sin embargo
luego de que la casa blanca anunciara
que probablemente no iba a invitar a
cuba a venezuela ni a nicaragua por no
respetar la carta interamericana de la
organización de estados americanos la
oea el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador dijo que no iría y
enviaría a su canciller marcelo ebrard
si las delegaciones de la habana caracas
y managua no asistían estas fueron las
palabras que iniciaron todo
insistir con el presidente by d
y que no se excluye a ningún país de
américa
en la cumbre
del mes próximo a celebrarse en los
ángeles california
y que las autoridades de cada país
decidan libremente
si asisten o no a dicho encuentro al
boicot de ambos se sumaron el presidente
de argentina alberto fernández la de
honduras xiomara castró el de bolivia
luis arce y las naciones del caricom con
la amenaza de que pudiera cancelarse el
evento la administración de joe biden
empezó a hacer una serie de movimientos
que no parecían casualidades como la
flexibilización de las sanciones
económicas a venezuela ya cuba y el
envío a buenos aires del ex senador y
asesor especial de la casa blanca crisis
that quien se reunió con funcionarios
argentinos y tras ese encuentro el
mandatario alberto fernández dio marcha
atrás y confirmó su participación en el
evento
por su parte en la habana se convocó una
cumbre improvisada de la alianza
bolivariana para los pueblos de nuestra
américa alba en la que se consideró un
retroceso para las relaciones
hemisféricas la decisión del anfitrión
de no invitar a miguel díaz-canel a
nicolás maduro y a daniel ortega valga
aclarar que en la antesala del evento no
hay una lista oficial de invitados y
parece que quedaron atrás entonces las
épocas doradas del evento que dejaron
imágenes como el histórico apretón de
manos entre el entonces presidente
estadounidense barack obama y raúl
castro- el líder de cuba o el anhelo
inaugural de
1994 de crear una zona libre de libre
comercio hemisférica para analizar nos
acompaña a guillermo coches él es ex
embajador de panamá ante la oea muchas
gracias por acompañarnos y empiezo por
preguntarle precisamente ha salido la
carta interamericana de la oea como la
razón por la cual nos invitaría a cuba a
venezuela ni a nicaragua a esta cumbre
que estipula esta carta interamericana
bueno la organización de estados
americanos tiene como su máxima dentro
de
los que tienen que cumplir sus miembros
el ser estado democrático ni nicaragua
ni venezuela y menos cuba pueden
argumentar que sus regímenes son
democráticos además tanto nicaragua como
venezuela han decidido no ser miembros
de la oea y cuba desde el 2009 cuando se
les reintegro a la oea no ha querido en
hacer su ingreso nuevamente simplemente
porque no puede cumplir con las reglas
democráticas organizadas establecidas
por la organización y plasmadas en la
carta interamericana
de la oea así que en ese sentido no hay
más nada que discutir
y podría decirse entonces que la cumbre
de la sociedad civil el evento paralelo
que también organiza la la oea ya la que
tradicionalmente han asistido
representantes de cuba podría ser más
importante que es lo que sale de este
encuentro paralelo
mira yo creo que no hay nada que impida
que se hagan dos eventos que ningún y
ninguno de los dos tendrá la importancia
que pudo tener la cumbre de las américas
en panamá en 2015 con los que tú
mencionaste de obama y raúl castro
simplemente porque cada vez la oposición
a la oea es mayor de parte de
argentina-méxico de los países que ya
han abandonado como nicaragua y
venezuela así que yo creo que es poco el
resultado aunque si puede tener algún
efecto las reuniones previas de la
cumbre de las américas la cumbre
paralela jamás ha tenido alguna
resonancia a nivel interamericano así
que la podrán hacer
un evento donde la gente tratará de
criticar a la oea de criticar a los
estados unidos y puntos y más nada
y brevemente le pregunto que gana el
presidente de méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador al convocar este tipo de boicot
a la cumbre de las américas contra eeuu
que es su mayor aliado económico
bueno es que lo que creo es que el
presidente lópez obrador cada vez se
está desvirtuando más de él porque lleva
al poder
'llevamos por la vida democrática cada
vez demuestra con sus actuaciones
internas y con sus actuaciones
internacionales que apoyan a
cuba-venezuela de nicaragua de que no
está sometido a los regímenes
democráticos a los principios que se
deben regir en méxico y en el resto de
américa latina es lastimoso porque el
pueblo de mexico votó por un gobernante
democrático no por alguien que cada vez
se aleja más del sistema democrático
agradecemos al ex embajador de panamá
ante la oea guillermo cochez por su
participación en aquí américa de
france24 y bueno aunque aún está por
verse quienes asistirán nosotros iremos
y los invitamos a seguir nuestro
cubrimiento especial de la cumbre de las
américas desde los ángeles del 6 al 10
de junio toda la información del evento
en una sección especial que
transmitiremos en directo américa
edición matinal y nocturna y vamos a
washington donde cada vez son más las
calles a las que se les cambia el nombre
como herramienta diplomática y política
por ejemplo cada vez que los
funcionarios de la embajada de arabia
saudita entran no sucede tienen que ver
el nombre de la calle llama el choque y
un periodista que fue asesinado por la
monarquía saudita un fenómeno que
urbanistas dicen que aumentó cuando se
rebautizó el nombre de la calle al
frente de la casa blanca black life
smarter plaza el informe desde nuestro
corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense cristóbal vázquez
diego d ambrosio fue considerado el
peluquero más famoso de washington en su
honor la ciudad puso su nombre a la
calle al frente de su negocio su hijo
fabricio ahora supervisa la peluquería
donde por más de 56 años al hilo ex
presidentes jueces diplomáticos
empresarios y otros de heres
yo creo que a la gente le hace falta de
hecho una mujer me dijo que no solamente
dejó un vacío en el barrio sino que dejó
un vacío en la ciudad lo que pintó es
concejal de washington y ha liderado el
cambio de nombres de las calles en la
capital estadounidense uno de los nuevos
cambios de nombre ir al frente de la
embajada de arabia saudita para recordar
el asesinato desde el periodista llama
al caso
este es un paso que podemos tomar
nosotros como ciudad para representar
los valores americanos de que nosotros
apoyamos la libre expresión libertad de
prensa y no retrocedemos frente a los
que nos intimidan entonces lo que
esperamos no es sólo nombrar esta calle
en honor alemán hans georg y sino enviar
un mensaje claro
en los próximos meses se cambiara el
nombre de la calle al frente de los
edificios del watergate en honor a la
juez ruth báder ginsburg también es
alcalá casablanca se pondrá el nombre
del congresista fallecido john lewis
para hablar con el director del
laboratorio de sostenibilidad urbana del
wilson center el cambio de nombres en
las calles de washington aumentó tras la
ola de manifestaciones de blacklight
matters
la ciudad estableció una comisión
principalmente de historiadores para
revisar el nombre de las calles y
edificios públicos importantes en el
distrito de columbia
urbanistas aclaran que el cambio de
nombre de las calles no afecta a la
nomenclatura de la ciudad sin embargo
cambiar o agregar nombres genera una
carga política que recibe y que el
espacio público y la vida a sus
referentes
vamos a venezuela la comunidad trans
denuncia que a pesar de que en el país
tiene derecho a cambiar de nombre y de
género en su documento de identidad el
poder electoral y el servicio de
identificación no están permitiendo
realizar el trámite venezuela sigue
siendo uno de los países más atrasados
en la región en cuanto a identidad de
género y derechos de la comunidad lgtb
de iq más el informe es de nuestros
corresponsales
igual
fumé quintero es una activista de
derechos humanos de la comunidad
transgénero en venezuela que ha luchado
durante 20 años por la igualdad de
género y la no discriminación
hoy ha visitado al parlamento como otras
tantas veces para exigir al poder
electoral y el servicio de
identificación del país poder cambiar de
nombre y de género el anteproyecto de
ley que permitiría expresamente el
trámite permanece guardado en la
asamblea nacional desde hace más de una
década lo digo con todo el peso que
tiene esto es falta de voluntad política
a diferencia del resto de américa latina
venezuela junto a paraguay son los
países con mayor atraso en cuanto al
cambio de género en la identidad para
las personas trans la persona va a
buscar el trabajo de la entrevista ni ya
cate cuando la va a contratar que pidan
los documentos le dicen que no ángel
pérez tiene 34 años es técnico superior
en enfermería haber cambiado su aspecto
físico de mujer a hombre le ha costado
varios puestos de trabajo desde hace dos
años está desempleado todas clínicas de
alta gama donde tú puedes presentar la x
escrita lograr todas las psicológicas
psicotécnicas pero cuando en tu
expresión de género y ven que tú tienes
una expresión masculina y un título
femenino puede estar el cargo y puede
haber la emergencia no va a entrar ángel
presta servicio comunitario de
enfermería en este módulo de atención
primaria manejado por el gobierno él
también ha sufrido discriminación el
producto de parte de funcionarios
públicos vestirse como hombre lo ha
llevado a ser detenido por supuesta
usurpación de identidad ya no para
margarita me detuvieron porque yo iba a
traficar droga porque esa cédula no
correspondía con lo que yo veía en el
caso de venezuela la mayoría de personas
trans están limitadas a unos pocos
oficios room y logra abrirse paso como
instructora de danza pero se considera
una excepción recientemente el
ministerio público anunció la creación
de una fiscalía especializada para
atender a las personas de la comunidad
sexo diversa una pequeña batalla ganada
en la lucha contra la no discriminación
que adelanta esta comunidad
y terminamos en ciudad de mexico porque
uno de los 16 barrios en los que está
dividida la capital del país
norteamericano pierde sus colores por
decisión de un mandatario local se trata
de sandra cuevas la alcaldesa de
cuauhtémoc un barrio que abarca el
centro histórico y los tradicionales
sectores de la condesa roma y juárez
ella decidió reemplazar los coloridos
letreros que adornaban cientos de
puestos de comidas en un esfuerzo por
según sus palabras limpiar la imagen de
la ciudad ahora sólo es posible ver
siluetas y un anuncio del gobierno local
lo que muchos colectivos rechazan al
considerar los anuncios como parte de la
identidad de la ciudad
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
giovanni agudelo pueden ver esta emisión
y las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas sigan
viendo france24
[Música]